it's Groundhog Day specifically it's
Brett Kavanaugh is Groundhog Day as the
left repeats again and again the same
lame spurious attacks on the Supreme
Court justice that they tried during his
confirmation hearings we examine the new
allegations why the left is launching
them now and why nobody knows anything
then Joe Biden recounts a story about
the time he almost whipped a razor blade
wielding black gang leader named corn
pop with a six foot long metal chain the
mainstream media blackout a shocking
abortion story and Mitt Romney reminds
us how lucky we are that he lost in 2012
all that and more on Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show gotta
get through the New York Times because
we gotta get to corn pop later on today
but this Times story on Cavanaugh tells
you so much about the modern left the
Democratic Party the Democratic Complex
and what they're thinking in 2020 the
timing of this is very interesting
because this story this totally botched
failed hit job by the New York Times on
Brett Kavanaugh ties in very nicely with
a peggy noonan column that came out a
few days ago and the Peggy Noonan column
was titled everyone knows the truth
about politics it was based on the ten
rules for life not Jordan Peterson but
James Burnham's ten rules for life James
Burnham was a political philosopher he
was a former leftist he became a
conservative and then he helped found
National Review you know he was a real
hardcore leftist he had a personal
correspondence with Leon Trotsky and
then he becomes the central figure in
the post-war conservative movement he
had ten laws ten rules for life he could
have been a best-seller if he lived
today the first law that he put out is
everybody knows everything and what this
means but how this applies today is the
idea that politicians aren't fooling
anybody that you can't actually conceal
that much from the people so the things
that candidates and prognosticators and
political operatives think are really
closely held secrets or not people just
know they get it you see the politician
you ain't hiding anything and a lot of
my left-wing friends don't understand
this they they just repeat the same
tired talking points that the left is
always regurgitating about Donald Trump
they repeat them to me as though we'd
never thought of that it had never
occurred to anyone one of my leftist
friends you know I'm here in New York
for a couple days I was seeing one of
every one of my friends as a liberal in
New York one of them comes up to me says
yesterday Michael it's just unfathomable
then a Christian could ever support
Donald Trump Donald Trump doesn't have
family values like this this has never
occurred to me before so oh you've gone
okay you got me I didn't realize Trump's
been married multiple times okay I don't
support him anymore right like that's
never occurred to me by the way just on
the point Donald Trump in a certain
sense really does have Family Values he
likes families so much that he's started
three of them likes marriage so much
he's done at three separate times
nevertheless the point is well-taken
president Trump has not led a
particularly upright life when it comes
to sex and love and marriage
okay that's fine the funny thing about
the talking point is not that the funny
thing is the left thanks Cabot nobody's
thought about this the Conservatives
don't get this we only we know this we
know it we know that President Trump who
has bragged about laying down with
ladies who isn't who are and his wife
rather has laid down with ladies who
aren't his wife we know that everybody
knows that stuff is baked into the
calculus of support for president Trump
why do Christians support Trump not
because of his marriage habits but [ __ ]
because generally speaking he is better
than the alternative much better than
the alternative incredibly better than
the alternative that's why it's very
simple everybody knows everybody knows
everything about Donald Trump especially
but what occurred to me with this
Cavanaugh hit with the dump with the New
York Times trying to dredge up these
same tired lame lies about Brett
Kavanaugh it occurred to me that there
is a corollary to Burnham's law that
everybody knows everything which is that
nobody knows anything how can those two
things be true at the same time because
everybody does know everything but
nobody ever seems to remember that
everybody knows everything and so in
another sense nobody knows anything the
left is the great example here the left
has been
sobbing three attacks and really only
three attacks since 2016 and they're
lobbing them again and again and again
like it's Groundhog Day over and over
and over we'll get to those three
attacks we'll get to have the New York
Times flopped on them we'll get to what
this means for 2020 but first I've got
to thank my friends over at Quicken
Loans support for the Michael no show
comes from our friends at rocket
mortgage by Quicken Loans I live in LA
it's very difficult to find a house
because you find a house it's like a
little shack with you know half a
bathroom and maybe a pile of hay that
you can sleep in and it's still like
eight million dollars so I don't really
like looking for houses in LA but the
good thing is once I find the home of my
dreams getting a mortgage will be easy
because of Quicken Loans you know rocket
mortgage is the number one I mean they
are there with award-winning client
service and support every step of the
way when you go into buying a home this
is most likely going to be the most
important financial decision you ever
make in your life for the vast majority
of people and because I'm a I'm a
millennial I never learned anything
practical barely learned how to balance
a checkbook so when you go into that
decision don't go in with the second
best or the third best or go in blind go
in with number one nine years in a row
where Quicken Loans is ranked the
highest and customer satisfaction for
primary mortgage origination six years
in a row ranked the highest in warriors
servicing go with the best when you work
with them you get more than just alone
because rocket mortgage is more than
just a lender get started today online
at rocket mortgage.com slash Knolls KO
wles
rocket mortgage calm slash journals
Equal Housing lender licensed in all 50
states
a MLS consumer access debt or number 30
30 rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans push
button get mortgage so this is this is
what we're struggling with everybody
knows everything the people do know
everything you're not going to fool the
people and yet nobody knows anything
because people keep forgetting that
first rule since 2016 the left has
hurled three attacks on Donald Trump on
Trump's associates and on Trump
supporters those attacks are that we are
racists or rapists or traitors it's one
of the three and when it gets to Trump
himself
they say he's all three he's a rapist I
got some unfounded allegations from
someone somewhere that's all they ever
seemed to do these
dey's he's a racist even though he's
condemned racism a zillion times doesn't
matter they call him a racist
everybody knows Trump's a racist that's
what they said all over the democratic
debate a few nights ago and he's a
traitor he's a stooge of Moscow he's
he's working for Vladimir Putin he's
selling out his country for golf courses
or something I don't know and the more
this is disproved the more that the
Muller report comes out shows Trump
never had any collusion didn't never had
any criminal conspiracy with Russia
nothing even resembling that doesn't
matter they dredge it up again and again
and again like Groundhog Day right now
second verse same as the first with
Brett Kavanaugh they called him a rapist
back when he was up for the Supreme
Court completely baseless allegations no
corroboration whatsoever constantly
changing storylines a ton of evidence to
the contrary didn't matter they went
forward with it they pushed it again and
again they said he almost raped a girl
they whipped out little Brett junior at
a party freshman year that he was
harassing girls one very prominent
Democratic lawyer Michael avenatti
claims that Brett Kavanaugh was part of
a gang rape cabal in Georgetown that
would go and find these poor women and
hold them down and do all sorts of crazy
things obviously no evidence for any of
that and of a number of them were proven
Liars including the most famous one
Christine Blasi Ford so what are they
doing now after this completely blows up
in their face stymies their attempts to
retake the Senate in 2018 totally fires
up Republicans what do they do now the
same freakin thing again and they're
doing it again
not because they believe the allegations
are true they don't nobody believes that
Breck haven't was a race a rapist rather
nobody now now one person in this
country seriously believes it who's
hurling these allegations but they're
doing it because they think they can
fool the American people they learn
nothing they are doing it on the left
because they think there's so much
cleverer than everybody else
the trouble is everyone knows everyone
knows this is BS except for them they
know it's BS too but they don't know
that everybody knows that it's BS here
is the attack New York Times New York
Times opinion tweets out get ready for
this quote
having a penis thrust in your face at a
drunken dorm party may seem like
harmless fun but when Brett Kavanaugh
did it to her
Debbie Ramirez says it confirmed that
she didn't belong at Yale in the first
place so I just like to rewind a little
bit to get into the premise here of the
New York Times tweet apparently
according to the New York Times having a
penis thrust into your face is harmless
fun there are a lot of things that that
implies a lot of roads you could take
that observation down from the New York
Times a lot of psychology of The Times
editors that is really bubbling to the
surface in this tweet I'm not going to
touch it not gonna touch it pun intended
but that was the first allegation
they're saying Brett Kavanaugh whipped
out little Brett junior at a party and
it ruined this girl's Yale career now if
you look for that tweet right now you're
not gonna find it why because the New
York Times repeated a refrain that
they've had to repeat I don't know like
every day in the last few weeks they
sent out another tweak what we deleted a
previous tweet regarding this article
that was offensive and we apologize now
that not only was it offensive by the
way and it was offensive
to those who don't think having that
thrust into your faces harmless fun but
it's inaccurate there's no evidence that
any of this happened and they had to
retract or update in their terms but
really retract and even crazier
allegations so building on the Debbie
Ramirez allegation that Brett whipped
out little Brett junior one day freshman
year they are now saying this is the
original New York Times allegation just
came out quote a classmate max tire saw
mr. Cavanaugh with his pants down at a
different drunken dorm party where
friends pushed his penis into the hand
of a female student
mr. steyr who runs a nonprofit
organization in Washington notified
senators in the FBI about this account
but the FBI did not investigate and mr.
steyr has declined to discuss it
publicly there's a lot to unpack in that
statement the first thing to note though
is even what if what the New York Times
is describing is true and by the way
there's no evidence that it is true
we'll find that out in a moment even if
it were true
what they are describing is not a sexual
assault by Brett Kavanaugh what they are
describing is a sexual assault on Brett
Kavanaugh because Brett Kavanaugh is not
the one doing the pushing or the
thrusting even the times in the original
story rights friends pushed his penis
into the hand of a female student not to
cause you too much trouble in your
mind's eye right now but just if you
would try to imagine the logistics of
that if some friends some friends they
are go in and they push little Brett
junior into a into the hands of the
female student so I guess the female
students hands are already out there
sort of waiting to receive something and
then the other friends get close enough
to little little Brett II know that they
can push it but they're also close
enough to the hands of the girl who
apparently is eagerly awaiting this
experience and push it it doesn't really
make a lot of sense visually when you
try to picture what's happening here
none of it makes sense and if anything
Kavanagh is the victim here because some
friends ostensibly
are grabbing his little brat II know now
what actually happened there's an
editor's note there's an update
September 15 2019 an earlier version of
this article which was adapted from a
forthcoming book did not include one
element of the books account regarding
an assertion by a Yale classmate that
friends of Brett Kavanaugh pushed his
penis into the hand of a female student
at a drunken dorm party the book reports
that the female student declined to be
interviewed and friends say she does not
recall the incident that information has
been added to the article so the girl
who even if the assault had not been on
Brett Kavanaugh which is what it
actually describes and then I guess
through the transitive property onto
this girl the girl in question says it
didn't happen she has no recollection of
it whatsoever so then you look back and
you say wait a second who's even making
the allegation then the allegation is
being made by a guy named Matt mr. steyr
max tyre who's max
dier they say he's a classmate of
Cavanaugh is a Yale and he runs a
nonprofit in Washington when you look
even one google search into this guy you
find out he's not just some nonprofit
obscure person in Washington he's a
lawyer for the Clintons specifically he
was a lawyer on Bill Clinton's Monica
Lewinsky scandal he was a lawyer
defending Bill Clinton against sexual
harassment allegations that turned out
to be completely true and he was
defending that guy but now he's going
after Kavanaugh and completely
fabricating an incident here that the
woman in question who that he says was
assaulted says didn't happen she has no
recollection of it so now the new here's
the new version of the New York Times
because they get caught with their hands
in the cookie jar they get caught lying
then they update it update retraction
and even then they say okay the new
version it classmate max tire saw mr.
Cavanaugh with his pants down at a
different drunken dorm party where
friends pushed his penis into the hands
of a female student
mr. steyr notified the Senators of this
account we corroborated the story with
two officials who have communicated with
mr. steyr the female declined to be
interviewed and friends say she does not
recall the episode so what they've added
here is they corroborated the story
okay good they corroborated so then the
woman says that it happened and there's
another eyewitness who says it happened
right that that would be what actual
corroboration would be no none of that
happened the woman doesn't have any
recollection of it at all they
corroborated the story by talking to two
officials officials of what officials of
Yale dorm parties officials what
officials are you talk to but it just
makes it sound really official when they
say that doesn't say what kind of
officials they are two officials who
communicated with mr. steyr so they
corroborated it by talking to two random
people who heard it from the same guy
that they're trying to corroborate his
account in other words they didn't
corroborate it at all this is of all the
New York Times stupid hit pieces this is
the dumbest most transparent most
illiterate journalistic malpractice I've
ever heard of and it's not just a Times
article it's two New York
times reporters who were excerpting this
and adapting this from a book they've
got out trying to smear Brett Kavanaugh
it's called the education of Brett
Kavanaugh and investigation all
completely bogus we'll get into how it's
bogus but more importantly more
importantly than just showing how all of
these people accusing Cavanaugh are
proven demonstrated hack liars
up to and especially including Christine
Blasi Ford before we get to that though
and before we get to the significance of
this why it's coming up now we have got
to thank our friends at Daniels and YC
you know how much I love this company
Daniels NYC makes superb briefcases
superb looking superb quality it's the
best briefcase I've ever had and I've
had great briefcases by the way I have
always made a point of having really
nice briefcases ostrich leather or all
these kind of great vintage briefcases
the Daniels briefcase is my favorite one
hands down this is why it's so important
because I look around today especially
you travel at the airport or whatever
and you see all these Millennials
wearing business suits walking down the
streets of New York business suits with
backpacks like their twelve-year-old
boys this is so frustrating to me
sometimes you see grown men doing grow
up guys come on it's take some integrity
in what you're doing take a little have
a little respect for yourself use a
briefcase daniels is a New York
city-based men's leather briefcase brand
best part about this let's say you're
right out of school you're going in for
that job interview maybe you can't
afford a briefcase to get a decent
briefcase usually five six seven hundred
bucks to get like anything even close to
nice Daniel's you can by cutting out the
middlemen they sell directly to you you
were able to get a high quality luxury
leather briefcase at the unbelievably
reasonable price of a hundred and ninety
five dollars there you're not gonna
touch anything even near this quality
for less than five hundred one hundred
ninety five bucks they look great they
are the perfect proportions they're not
like these jumbo things for back when
computers were like you know it's three
feet long they're perfectly tailored
with this wonderful old New York style
they've got really cool linings I've got
this slight kind of Fox motif inside it
just looks great it feels great get it
get it right now seriously look like an
adult look sleek it's awesome my
listeners can get this week twenty-five
bucks off their Daniels briefcase at
Daniels and
why c.com by using the promo code
michael mi CH AE l 25% 25 bucks rather
off and already incredibly inexpensive
briefcase exceptional quality plus free
shipping do it
Daniel's NYC comm promo code michael mi
CH AE l handcrafted high-quality leather
briefcases with free shipping ditch the
backpack look like a grown-up have some
self-respect
Daniel's NYC comm promo code Michael I
love their leather briefcases you will
too
so all this stuff about Kavanagh
completely bogus Christine Blasi Ford
changed her story multiple times there's
no evidence that she ever met red
Cavanaugh we just found out last week
her father supported Brett Kavanaugh his
confirmation her father went up to his
father at a country club that they both
belong to and more or less apologized
for his daughter's lunatic hacks cynical
disgusting behavior her lawyer
Christine Blasi Ford's lawyer Deborah
Katz admitted on video that her
testimony was at least in part motivated
by her insane infanticidal desire to
keep Roe vs. Wade in place here's her
attorney Deborah Katz you will always
have an asterisk next to his name when
he takes a scalpel to roe v-- wade we
will know who he is
we know his character and we know what
motivates him and that is important it
is important that we know and that was
part of what motivated Christine that's
part of what motivated Christine is she
wants to keep killing babies she wants a
lot of women to keep killing a million
babies a year and so she's gonna
completely make up a story by the way
for the people who say that Christine
Blasi Ford was telling the truth the
question you've got to ask them is when
was she telling the truth there were
three guys in the room then there were
four guys then there were five guys then
it was this guy than it was that guy
then she's pretty sure Cavanaugh was
there but I don't know and when was the
party she doesn't know where was the
party have no idea how did it happen
couldn't possibly tell you she changed
her story like four or five times
officially not even just a random people
she well speaking to the Senate changed
her story multiple times so for those of
you who are saying she was honest she
was telling the truth when was she
telling the truth
okay if you believe that one time is
when she was telling the truth all the
other times she was lying or
misremembering which would be the
charitable way to put it
but if she's miss remembering that event
that happened
thirty years ago maybe then I don't
think her memory is terribly reliable on
the other details either the Ramirez
thing that Brett Kavanaugh pulled out
little bratty know when he was a
freshman had no corroboration at all
Ramirez wouldn't come forward to
corroborate this eventually she kind of
came out and became public about it but
they tried to get anyone else in the
room to say that it happened no one
would do it even Leland Keyser Leland
Keyser was Christine Blasi for his best
friend allegedly at the same party she
said she had no recollection of this
happening she didn't believe it just
nothing then we got to Julie sweat Nick
this was another crazy accuser came out
of the woodwork
Michael avenatti dug her up at us
somewhere and she said that brick have
inaugurated her that allegation
completely fell apart and the mainstream
media stopped talking about it so now we
have another claim made by another
lunatic on behalf of someone with
absolutely no recollection of it why are
they trying this again when it hurt them
so bad and for the first time the main
reason the main reason that they are
trying it again is they got nothing to
run on they can't run on the economy
they can't run wars in the Middle East
they can't run on anything really I mean
everything is going pretty well in the
country can't run on manufacturing can't
run on trade policy can't run on
immigration because their immigration
views are very unpopular so instead
they're just trying to repeat the same
failed strategies over and over and over
rapist racist traitor
I think the second reason why they're
bringing this up is Ginsburg's health
justice RBG came out you know she's been
being treated for cancer she's had
radiation treatment all summer
she hasn't been showing up to court
she's very elderly in to begin with so
even if she had a good bill of health
you never know when she's going to leave
the court either voluntarily or
involuntarily and so they want to ramp
this up to try to get the Democrat base
juiced for the judges in the 2020
election that's the other but the third
reason this is kind of the underlying
reason is they don't the left doesn't
learn anything they don't get it they
don't know nothing and what they don't
know nothing about especially is that
everybody knows everything it's so
transparent that if the left had even a
modicum of respect for the American
people
would say hmm yeah that one didn't work
we didn't pull the wool over their eyes
last time let's not try it again it's
really insulting the American people's
intelligence to try this this nonsense
with them but they don't have any
respect for the American people so
they're gonna try it again and again and
again and it's hilarious to watch from
the sidelines I feel bad for Brett
Kavanaugh because he is having his
reputation tarnished but the good news
on it is nobody believes this nonsense
to show you what this is all about
because what this Boyle this judge thing
boiled down to was abortion right
Christine Blasi Ford's attorney says she
was motivated by trying to keep Roe
versus Wade what does that mean we hear
a woman's right to choose we hear the
war on women women's health what does
that mean there's a story just came out
of South Bend Indiana
there was an abortion doctor who died
there on September 3rd dr. rich Klopfer
he just sounds evil doesn't he's got an
evil sounding name they found on his
property 2246 fetal remains on his
property in South Bend 2246 dead baby
parts that this sicko collected he
killed the babies than he collected
their body parts took them home and
saved them for what purpose I don't even
want to begin to imagine the story here
is not that the abortionist is a
sociopath all abortionists or sociopaths
I should say with son I should put a
caveat here the abortionists who don't
repent or sociopaths there have been
some people who have worked in the
abortion industry and then they've
gotten out and said this is so
horrifying I mean dr. Bernard Nathanson
he was one of the guys who founded nay
RAL the pro-abortion
organization biggest one in the country
he was performing abortions and he came
out now he's a major pro-life advocate
Abby Johnson obviously an unplanned she
worked in the abortion industry now
she's one of the biggest pro-life
advocates but the ones who don't repent
the ones who just keep it going they're
all sociopaths so this is not a
surprising story the story here just
like in the Kermit Gosnell case another
six sociopath abortionist who saved
little baby parts as mementos of the
babies he killed
and the real story here is the media
won't cover it the media won't cover it
the same media that are hurling these
completely baseless smears at the right
at a Supreme Court justice at
conservatives that same media when you
get a major story like this abortionist
has 2,200 baby parts in his home they
don't cover it just like they didn't
cover Gosnell you know Kermit Gosnell
biggest mass murderer in American
history killed all these babies the
babies would be born and then he would
kill them wasn't even killing them just
before they were born when they were
having his trial when when he was in
front of the judge they had a whole
section for the media the section was
empty nobody showed up because they
don't want to talk about it this story
is almost exclusively being covered by
local news and conservative outlets you
very likely haven't heard about it
anywhere other than this show or maybe
you saw it on The Daily wire or
something you certainly didn't read
about it in the Washington Post or the
New York Times just CNN same story with
Gosnell the left is vicious and the
leftist media in particular is sort of
leading the way here they are so vicious
they have absolutely no credibility they
have absolutely no standards and the
stakes of this battle are high 2246 dead
baby parts by the way there was no
evidence that the guy ever performed any
of these procedures at his home more
likely he performed the procedures at a
doctor's office and then kept them and
took them home as souvenirs that is some
sick stuff and you have an entire
Democrat media complex covering up for
it and meanwhile distracting with more
completely baseless allegations of rape
can you imagine joking about rape lying
about rape on the cover of the New York
Times because that's what it is it's
making a mockery of rape it's it's doing
such a disservice to all the actual
victims of rape by saying now we're
gonna use this as a cudgel isn't true we
know it's not true don't care might be
useful in that way we get to protect
abortionists like dr. Ullrich Klopfer
who take home 2,200 baby body parts as
mementos to do whatever sick stuff he's
going to do with it
his own home this shows us the utility
of Trump this shows us the importance of
elections this shows us the importance
of electing that guy that a lot of
people didn't like in 2016 a lot of that
election was about the conservative
judges Brett Kavanaugh gets on the court
they were so furious they're still
trying to get him kicked off the court
they're still trying to impeach him
that's how important it was to the left
to keep him off the court that was what
the 2016 election was about these babies
Trump has had great abortion policy you
still hear people on the Left they say
well Trump used to be pro-choice hell he
might have paid for a couple abortions
himself we don't know even if all of
that were true he's been great on
abortion he's put up a lot of
originalist judges he's been great on
abortion policy he secretly defunded 10
percent of Planned Parenthood just by
changing title 10 he reinstituted the
Mexico City policy so we're not funding
abortions overseas he's been superb on
abortion policy those are the stakes
that is the importance that's the
utility what it also does it is it
throws into stark relief the flip side
of that you know we looked at the flip
side of the James Burnham law everybody
knows everything
nobody knows nothing you see the flip
side of this the importance of a guy
like Trump who maybe you don't like him
personally maybe you find him
distasteful but he's really doing great
things the flip side of that is the
uselessness in the counter productivity
of spineless Republicans and fake
conservatives the Mitt Romney's of the
world Mitt Romney the story with him I
don't even want to talk about him wastes
time on the show but the story is he is
not going to endorse anybody in 2020
he's not gonna do it why would he
endorse somebody in 2020 it doesn't
matter
sure you've got the Democrat media
complex smearing good men mocking rape I
mean making a whole mockery of the crime
of rape trying to cover up for people
who who keep the mementos and souvenirs
of 2,200 babies that they've killed yes
sure you got that going on but you know
the tweets mm there you key I don't like
the tweet so Mitt Romney completely
useless not going to endorse he probably
would endorse somebody else if he could
but he knows he'd probably lose a Senate
seat if he did that he
doesn't understand the cultural battle
that we're in or else he doesn't care it
it just gets to me when I you know I
sometimes go off on the people who say I
call them the Conservatives but not that
kind of conservatives they're the
Conservatives we'll all they ever want
to do is criticize other conservatives
and the minute that the New York Times
looks their way they turn beet red they
get so excited their heart goes
pitter-patter
oh please left love me love me the Mitt
Romney types Mitt Romney was always like
this you know there's this idea I think
among some people the I guess whatever
the remainder of the never Trump wing
you know the three people who are
running against him and maybe Bill
Kristol those guys have kind of
constructed this narrative that somebody
like Mitt Romney was somehow more
conservative had more integrity than
Donald Trump
he doesn't just a little reminder just a
quick little reminder of Mitt Romney's
political legacy here's Romney endorsing
abortion and denigrating Ronald Reagan
so when asked well I preserve and
protect a woman's right to choose I make
an unequivocal answer yes I will
preserve and protect a woman's right to
choose and have devoted and dedicated to
honoring my word in that regard I will
not change any provisions of
Massachusetts pro-choice laws look I was
an independent during the time of Reagan
Bush I'm not trying to return to Reagan
Bush my positions don't talk about
things that you suggest they talk about
you're right you're right you are you're
an independent you're a liberal that's
what he is and I'm just so sick of this
idea that Romney and the Romneys of the
world is this dignified statesman these
true conservatives and and the people
who support Trump are not true
conservatives Romney's not a true
conservative he's an empty suit liberal
shill who will say absolutely anything
to get elected and has no loyalty to any
principle or any party because he
doesn't have any principles and he only
has a party when it's convenient to him
the stakes are too high for Mitt
Romney's the stakes are too high look at
the New York Times which has been so
dishonest for so many years but is just
basically coming all out with it now and
saying yeah we're not a newspaper we're
not we're just here to smear any
conservative that we don't like based on
absolutely nothing and then when we get
called out for getting the facts
completely wrong we're not
I'm really going to admit it we're still
gonna hide a lot of stuff the stakes are
too high for this and they're there the
left is just repeating this game again
and again at higher and higher intensity
you know President Trump has a lot of
vulnerabilities going into 2020 the
stakes are too high the one bit of good
news though by the way is the guys going
up against him our week we will get to
Joe Biden telling about the old gangster
that he once almost whipped with a metal
chain corn popped the gangster and we'll
get to a pop star coming out as
gender-neutral a lot more to get to but
you got to go to daily wire comm ten
bucks a month hundred dollars for an
annual membership you get me you get the
Andrew Klavan show you got the ben
shapiro show you get the mount wall show
you get to ask questions in the mailbag
coming up on thursday you get another
Kingdom which is gonna be fantastic this
season and you get the left is tears
tumblr you're gonna need it Joe Biden's
gonna need it
probably corn pop is gonna need it to
head on over to Daley wire calm we'll be
back with a lot more
my absolute favorite story today I mean
the main story obviously is this
Cavanaugh thing but my favorite story
favorite one of all Joe Biden telling a
tale about corn pop this video is not
from the campaign trail apparently I
think it's like a year or two old but it
tells you so much about Joe Biden it
tells you why his campaign is so
outdated and it tells you why he's been
so weak as a presidential candidate for
his entire career here's Joe Biden
recounting the absolutely totally true
not at all made-up story about the time
he almost whipped corn pop with a metal
chain and corn pop was a bad dude and he
ran a bunch of bad boys and I did yeah
and back in those days and shot things
have changed one of the things had to
use if you use pomade in your hair you
had to wear a bathing cap and so he's up
on the board wouldn't listen I said hey
Esther you off the board or I'll come up
and drag you off well he came off and he
said I'll meet you outside my car this
was mostly these are all public housing
behind it my car there was a gate out
here I parked my car outside the gate
and I said I'll be waiting for you late
burns three guys and straight razors not
a joke there's a guy named Bill
right-mouse the only white guy and he
did all the pools he was the mechanic
and I said what am I going to do he said
come down here in the basement where
mechanics where all the pool builder is
you know the chain that used to be a
chain that went across the deep end and
he cut off a six-foot length of chain
you fold up he said you walk out with
that chain and you walked in a car and
say you may cut me man but I'm gonna
wrap this chain around your head it goes
on I'll just spoiler alert Joe Biden
didn't wrap the chain around corn pops
head corn pop didn't slice him with the
razor they all went on with their lives
and lives happily ever after they lived
happily ever after I used that phrase
because this is obviously a fable this
is a fairy tale it never happened nobody
thinks it happened everybody knows that
happen and Joe Biden isn't fooling
anybody but there's so much wrong in
this story corn pop almost certainly
does not exist it reminds me of when
Cory Booker talked about his old drug
dealer friend t-bone in Newark said yeah
my old buddy t-bone and I we had this
relationship and you know I'd see him on
the streets of Newark and so somebody
realized you know Cory Booker there is
no way that you oxford-educated Yale
educated very nice guy looks good in a
good suit with a nice time you have
never once in your whole life met a guy
named t-bone possibly because nobody has
actually named t-bone that's that's what
a kind of preppy nice guy who goes to
good schools and wear suits and runs for
the Senate that's like the caricature of
what he thinks guys on the streets of
Newark are like t-bone eventually Cory
had to come out and admit the t-bone is
a fictitious person but the way he tried
to spin it as he said he's a composite
character of lots of different figures
in my life so that's another word for
you completely made him up what you mean
I couldn't there are no composite people
in the world there are people and then
there are people that you make up and
the people you make up or t-bone corn
pop is gonna be one of these two what it
tells you is a little bit of how Joe
Biden views the world how Joe Biden
views race relations because what this
is essentially about is race and
reaching across the aisle and race
reaching across the racial divide he
said he was pretty much the only white
guy there may be one or two other white
guys everyone else in the neighborhood
was black but he wasn't gonna be cowed
and he wasn't gonna he was gonna forge a
real relationship with corn pop he was
gonna get the respect of all those black
people and he was gonna show we're not
so different after all corn pop we're
gonna live together in society I guess
that's what it's about nobody's buying
this nobody's buying this at all the
other reason I actually don't think
that's gonna kill him totally it's not
good for him but it's part and parcel of
his whole career which is lying and
making things up and stealing stories
and creating false narratives it's the
references the references he's making
are so dated a corn pop I mean I guess
he's talking
a character from the past so fine but it
just reminds you man joe biden's really
old but then he yells out he says hey
Esther he's talking about it was it
Esther Williams if a famous swimmer from
you know like that
13 50s or whatever this story allegedly
occurred 60 years ago or something hey
Esther people aren't even named Esther
anymore I mean it's just everything
about this story reminds you how
unbelievably old this guy is and it's
not that he's old it's that he seems old
Trump is older to the unsee mold Ronald
Reagan was older when he was president
he didn't seem all they seemed young Joe
Biden has that problem and what it comes
down to for him is that everybody knows
it what the whole Biden campaign is
based on the electability Joe Biden's so
electable and what what the electability
argument means is look I an educated
smart good person wouldn't really like
Joe Biden and don't want to vote for him
but all those idiot masses out there
could get behind him all those dumb
people who you know they're not like me
because I'm so smart and good and so
because all those idiots like him he'll
be a good candidate Hey Dude you're not
that much smarter than everybody else
you're probably not smarter than
everybody else at all you might very
well be dumber than everybody else and
if everybody is thinking that which they
are cuz everybody knows everything then
he's not the most electable candidate
he's just pretend electable he's
electable in this imaginary world were
you in your arrogance think that you're
so much smarter than everybody else but
you're not everybody knows everything
except the people the experts the elites
the prognosticators the Joe Biden
himself who think that they're hiding
this reality from everybody they don't
know nothing but everybody does know
everything they see it you can't conceal
these realities from people these videos
are going to keep coming out and out and
out if the Democratic Party is serious
about winning the election if they wise
up they've got to get over their own
pride they have to have a little
humility they have to have a little
respect for the American people say hmm
you know if we're thinking it they might
be thinking it too let's give them a
serious candidate and not just Joe Biden
and corn pop something tells me though
they're not going to get that respect
for the American people and that's good
news for the right that's great news for
conservatives
another little little story here before
we go this is a story maybe you've read
about but probably you haven't because
it's about this singer Sam Smith I
actually like Sam Smith he's got a
couple good Tunes but obviously I don't
it's not like I'm waiting in line
they're downloading his albums or
anything like that
the reason Sam Smith matters right now
is he just came out big pop star Grammy
winner and he declared for the third
time in less than a year that he is
neither a man nor a woman now the reason
this matters not because of Sam Smith's
music or anything because it shows you
the logical end of the gender identity
movement so Sam Smith posts now now for
the third time on instagram he says
quote I've decided I am changing my
pronouns to they slash them after a
lifetime of being at war with my gender
I've decided to embrace myself for who I
am
inside and out I'm so excited and
privileged to be surrounded by people
that support me in this decision but
I've been very nervous about announcing
this because I care too much about what
people think but effin I understand
there will be many mistakes and
misgendering but all I ask is you please
please try I hope you can see me like I
see myself now so that's what he just
said he also said all of this back in
March
he also said all of this back in October
this is a ploy for attention he may be
confused about his sexuality think he's
homosexual although now I don't know if
he's homosexual because if you're
homosexual it means you're attracted to
people of the same sex and now he's
saying he's not not a man but I think
he's still attracted to man but he
doesn't have any sex at all so it's very
very confusing I'm at least as confused
as he is but it's the constant play for
attention and it's a play for sympathy I
mean it shows you the logical end of the
gender identity movement just in this
particular case because the next time
he's up for a Grammy they're not gonna
know what category to put him in is
they're gonna put him in with a male
artist category I mean he's got a beard
and he is a man or are they gonna put
him in the female artist category
he's not at all a woman there's nothing
about him as a woman he doesn't even
look feminine I guess they're not gonna
put him in that but
really what they're probably gonna do is
just abolish sex categories for these
awards anyway even though men and women
sound very different musically have very
different voices makes perfect sense for
them to have separate categories they're
going to abolish it because the logical
end of all of this is abolishing sexual
difference sexual difference is very
important there's a reason why every
creation story begins with sexual
difference
the book of Genesis in the beginning God
created man both male and female he
created them the reason that this this
has endured this understanding of
ourselves and our origin is because sex
really matters and the sexual difference
really matters men and women and that
explains much of the story of our lives
Gilgamesh there's an older story than
Genesis begins with sexual difference in
fact civilization begins when it kind of
ruffian wild beast eale man comes out of
the woods and has sex with a beautiful
woman the sacred prostitute that sexual
difference really matters what the left
wants to do though in this fantasy is
abolish sexual difference entirely and
they're almost certainly gonna do it at
the Grammys and the awards shows because
they're so far gone at this point they
have no it would take so long to argue
back to what we all know to be true
which is the men and women are different
so and now what what this guy sam smith
is doing in another play for attention
and sympathy is saying you have to refer
to me as ave then that is true and to
say otherwise it's miss gendering
misgendering but the only misgendering
is what he's doing is he is a he is a
man in fact even if he thought he were a
woman it would it would be better to
call him she or her than to call him
they or them because they or them means
that he is multiple people he might have
multiple personalities for all we know
but he isn't multiple people it is such
an assault in the english language it's
such an assault on logic and reason but
that is the illogical conclusion i guess
of the gender identity movement and he's
going to get the sympathy and he's going
to get the attention and the grammys are
almost certainly going to abolish sex
difference categories but people know it
isn't true
they know they know deep down
and the more the left insists on this
lie it shows you that the left is not
confident in what they believe in
because they're just bullying you all
the time if you don't if you don't say
that up is down you're a bigot if you
don't say that I'm multiple people and
you don't refer to he as they or them
you are an awful hateful bigot and you
will be ostracized and you'll lose your
job and you'll be kicked out of school
and you won't be invited to fun parties
anymore
if you don't go along with us if you
don't oppose Trump if you don't support
abortion if you don't support Roe versus
Wade we're gonna smear you as a rapist
we're gonna make up allegations against
you we're gonna put it on the cover of
the New York Times when we get called
out for our lies we're gonna double down
on them that is what they're telling you
they're telling you that because they
know that their fundamental arguments
are not connected to reality their
fundamental arguments aren't true if
you're describing things that are true
you don't need to be so hardcore about
it you don't need to be so intense and
so coercive you don't need to be so
insistent that everybody constantly
affirm your fantasies because you just
know it's true I don't need to go out
every day and say the sun is shining out
on the street the sun is shining
everybody say it the Sun is shut because
the sun is shining we all know it two
plus two equals four you have to say
that because we all know it's true but
it but if I were trying to convince
people to live in a world where two plus
two equals five I would have to make
them all say it again and again that's
the plot of 1984 by George Orwell the
way they finally break Winston in 1984
is by forcing him to say that two plus
two equals five that's how they get them
and they insist on it under torture
under duress and that is what they're
doing now and the more they double down
on that the more it's gonna hurt them in
the long run it is a fantasy it is not
sustainable because at the bottom
everybody knows reality everybody knows
everything and the people who are trying
to insist on that fantasy are going to
lose in the end and they're gonna lose
in part because they don't know anything
they don't even know that basic fact
everybody knows the reality in the party
that corresponds to reality the
political movement that corresponds to
reality that treats people with some
respect by telling them
that reality is reality that they don't
need to disbelieve their own eyes the
party that treats the world in that way
and treats people with that sort of
respect is in the long run going to win
that is bad news for the left that's our
show
come on back tomorrow in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
no show see you then
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director Pavel why
douse key edited by Danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by Mike core Amina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 on
the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you